heute startet mein video etwas anders
denn ich mache beim adventskalender 2014
mit mit ganz vielen anderen lieben
youtube an
unter anderem zum beispiel auch den
nicole von nicoles zuckerwerk und ich
bin heute am 12 12 und hab mir was
richtig leckeres ausgedacht ich wünsche
euch ganz viel spaß beim einem video die
anderen youtuber und die anderen kanäle
verlinkt ich euch alle gesamt in der
infobox
da könnt ihr mal reinschauen denn da
geht es schon richtig leckere sachen und
bis weihnachten gibt's da jeden tag ein
anderes rezept ich bin bereit und plus
hallo
herzlich willkommen in unserer
weihnachts edition
wir werden heute nichts backen heute
gibt es im richtig leckeres
weihnachtliches menü
ich habe ja auch schon letztes jahr ein
leckeres weihnachtsmenü gemacht da hat
ja der bülent ceylan vorher ein gedicht
für mich vorgetragen und ich habe ihm
dann was leckeres gekocht und dieses
video werde ich euch natürlich immer
infobox verlinken und da könnt ihr
einfach noch mal schauen was ich letztes
jahr gezaubert ob und dieses jahr werde
ich jetzt auch zwei menüs machen heute
gibt es jetzt ein menü mit fleisch und
das nächste mal gibt einfach ein
vegetarisches menü und bei unsicher so
ich muss natürlich gern nur sachen die
mir auch schmecken also ich mag es zum
beispiel nicht wenn man irgendwie
johannisbeeren mit dem essen hat oder
vanille ebene kartoffelpüree oder im
kartoffelbrei und deswegen gibt es so
etwas ganz einfaches was ganz leckeres
und was aber trotzdem richtig toll
aussieht
ich hätte nämlich heute ein leckeres
interstate machen dazu gibt's herzog in
kartoffeln und ein leckeres humus und
ich zeige euch jetzt mal schnell die
zutaten damit wir direkt loslegen können
ich brauche für meine herzog in
kartoffeln 500 gramm kartoffeln die sind
jetzt mehlig kochend
ich brauch 50 gramm butter in whistler
muskatnuss natürlich salz und pfeffer
und 2 eigelbe davon werde ich eins für
in den teig benutzen und einzustreichen
dessen hier die zutaten für mein steak
ich habe hier ein richtig schönes großes
rindersteaks habe es auch schon
abgetupft damit es trocken ist
ich brauche salz und pfeffer and
business so etwa ein teelöffel einen
teelöffel rosmarin und eventuell eine
knoblauchzehe und für mein humus brauche
ich jetzt kichererbsen aus der dose die
sind nämlich schon vorgegart und das ist
eine große dose mit 800 gramm
aber ich werde davon jetzt nur die
hälfte machen weil dieses menü so etwa
für drei personen gedacht ist es braucht
etwas kreuzkümmel den habe ich schon
gemahlen
das ist etwa ein halber teelöffel dann
mit große knoblauchzehe oder zwei kleine
halle
ich brauche ein bisschen zitronensaft
von einer zitrone dann gehört da noch
etwas sesampaste mit rein das ist
übrigens auch zwei produkte die bekommt
ihr auch normalerweise in allen großen
supermärkten von bagdad und ich brauche
einfach noch etwas olivenöl und ich habe
es jetzt schon so gemacht ich möchte
jetzt mit den kartoffeln stapeln weil
wir jetzt erstmal garen müssen und damit
ich die später leichter schälen kann
nehme ich jetzt die kartoffel und ritze
einfach außen rundherum ein bevor ich
sie gar
und dann kann nämlich später die schale
richtig leicht entfernt werden und das
habe ich jetzt einfach schon gemacht und
meine kartoffeln sind jetzt auch schon
hier in dem topf drin
die 500 gramm die kochen hier einfach
mit etwas wasser vor sich hin
und es dauerte ungefähr 20 minuten hat
sie gerade ein vakuum gebildet offen und
die lassen jetzt einfach auf dem herd
bis sie schön weich sind und in der zeit
bereit ich schon mal mein humus vor so
ich habe jetzt meinen mixa bereits
bereitgestellt ich mache das jetzt in
den mixer ihr könnt aber auch mit einem
stabmixer machen aber auf jeden fall
braucht gegen mixa damit er überhaupt
die kichererbsen klein bekommt die muss
ich jetzt aber erstmal abschließen und
ich werde jetzt heute nur die hälfte
mache und mit der anderen hälfte kann
man entweder irgendwann nochmal muss
machen oder ich kann zum beispiel mit
tomatensoße damit weiter arbeiten
irgendwas eben damit machen so zuerst
gebe ich jetzt meine knapp 18 oben rein
heißt kurz abtropfen
und die hälfte der kichererbsen und das
ist jetzt einfach mal kurz vernichten
nur ganz grob jetzt kommt von dieser
sesampaste mit dazu und bei der see
fantastisches so falls ihr die jetzt
nicht komplett auf braucht dann könnte
es einfach im kühlschrank stehen lassen
ich echt sehr lange haltbar da gebe ich
jetzt eineinhalb esslöffel dazu vorher
noch so ein bisschen verrühren das jetzt
sicherlich oft das öl oben ab und ich
gebe es noch ein bisschen von dieser
flüssigkeit wird rein damit es nicht zu
fest wird auch gleich den zitronensaft
ich nehme da jetzt mal noch nicht die
ganze zitrone schmeckt erst jetzt noch
kreuzkümmel daneben der entweder einen
halben teelöffel bis einen halben
esslöffel also je nachdem wie es der ihr
dieses gewürz mögt dann mit salz und
pfeffer abschmecken
ich hoffe jemand kleiner war als ich das
gibt damit gehen auf diese arbeitsplatte
mit dem mit dem mixer des zu hoch
schweiz aber keine anspielung auf
irgendjemanden und jetzt noch einen halb
esslöffel olivenöl
aber ich hatte euch auch dieses rezept
bereits im sommer gezeigt
und das ist einfach nur mal das gleiche
nur eben ein halber mängel
du musst 250 genau wie jetzt noch mal
richtig schön cremig vermissen noch
nicht ein bisschen zitrone und meiner
meinung nach fehlt auch noch ein
bisschen kümmel und etwas
jetzt war zugleich probleme mörder
kurzen abschnitten wenn es schmeckt
kriegst du auch also ich finde dass man
bis in mein kreuzkümmel nehmen ich mag
sein mit kreuzkümmel und du magst eher
weniger
und wenn man zu viele zitrone
reingeraten ist neben der iphone gruppe
sesampaste und ein paar kichererbsen und
ein vermisstes noch mal und dann ist
auch mein mann zufrieden und kreuzkümmel
kann ich mir dann auf dem teller mit
drauf
wie gut dass du so ähnlich groß
kein größten besetzung
ich fühle dass homo sitzung und stellt
kalt und kann mich auch gleich schon um
das fleisch gehört
ich habe hier mein steak und bett ist
jetzt mit etwas öl bestreichen
aber auch schwarz neutrales
sonnenblumenöl zb nehmen einfach es von
beiden seiten damit ich das jetzt gleich
anfahren kann er wird übrigens schon
heiß
ich würde das jetzt auch erst nach dem
motto da gibt's da immer diese
diskussion fordern 8 vortag
und jetzt kommt es in die heiße pfanne
rein
und wird jetzt von beiden seiten ganz
scharf so etwa eine halbe minute an
beraten
angenehm ist heraus gibt es natürlich
immer noch ganz froh aber das wird jetzt
ganz ganz langsam im ofen dann fertig
garen
aber jetzt gebe ich schon mal meinen
rosmarin da drauf setzt getrockneter
rosmarin
rosmarin total gerne wenn ihr das aber
nicht möglich könnte auch zum beispiel
etwas thymian oder andere kräuter nehmen
jetzt noch etwas pfeffer
und natürlich salz
ohne der knoblauchzehe reif ich es
einfach so ein bisschen ein kind ohne
dass der knoblauch geschmack dominiert
habe er schon genug im humus drin
richtig schade dass man es von beiden
seiten gut wirst das ist überall dran
kommt und von allen seiten richtig gut
schmeckt
doch immer so gemacht habe aber ich
schreibe ja meine mama dem markt ist
auch mit so halb fertig sie sagt immer
das stadtbüro aber ich mag halt in der
mitte noch größer ist
den teelöffel senf verteile gibt einfach
auf breite seiten und so kommt jetzt das
fleisch in den vorgeheizten backofen bei
150 grad bei mir wird etwa 15 20 bis 25
minuten brauchen
ich werde dann einfach zwischendurch mal
reinschauen wieder ist es um je nachdem
wie durch ihr das haben möchte muss es
eben etwas länger drin lassen
ich stelle das kurz rein und kann dann
meine kartoffeln weiterverarbeiten
ich habe es die kartoffeln schon
abgegossen und die sind noch sehr heiß
und ihr seht ihr schon dass die schale
sicher außenrum schon bereits löst und
es geht jetzt einfacher wenn wir die
einfach mal kurz in kaltes wasser
tauchen
erstens mal kühlen sie dann ganz trotz
ab und ich verbrenne mir nicht so arg
finger und zweitens man kann es dann
besser aus der schale drücken denn dann
bis ich nur rechts und links einfach
ziehen
es geht auf jeden fall viel einfacher
als wenn ihr eben die kartoffeln so
schön bunt und jetzt werde ich die
kartoffel noch zur stammt von mit seiner
süßen den fahrer kartoffelstampf jetzt
weiß auch der moral wozu dieses werkzeug
geeignet ist
markieren zuerst stellte
nein es sich zum kartoffelstampf früher
hat man so was er in küchen gesehen weil
früher die oma immer sowas selber
gemacht hat aber heute gibt es ja gerade
aus der tüte und knödel aus der tüte da
braucht man denn so und jetzt habe ich
die kartoffeln zerstampft sind natürlich
auch noch ein paar bröckchen drin aber
das ist nicht weiter schlimm hauptsache
sie gehen gleich durch den spritzbeutel
durch also so bisserl mister schon
darauf achtet dass ihr fein sind und
gehe lieber auf sicherheitshalber
nochmal durch und jetzt kommt hier ein
eigelb mit dazu ich habe jetzt hier zwei
stück in einem schälchen deswegen nur
die hälfte
dann wird es nach kurths eingerührt und
die kartoffeln sind jetzt noch warm
deswegen gebe ich dann noch die butter
mit rein
aber ich sah teils vor jetzt noch so in
flöckchen damit sie einfach besser
schmilzt und dann einfach durchführen
jetzt wird das ganze noch gesalzen und
gepfeffert eben für den geschmack da
nimmt er einfach so viel wie ihr möchtet
und bei mir kommt dann auch immer noch
ein bisschen muskatnuss mit rein die
musst du durch frisch gerieben sein
und da könnte eine ordentliche prise mit
dazu geben ich finde es ist sowas zu
kartoffeln auf jeden fall immer mit dazu
gehört
und dann einfach ordentlich verrühren
und jetzt habe ich mir einen
spritzbeutel zurechtgelegt in einen
spritzbeutel ständer
ich finde immer ganz praktisch wenn ich
dann beide hände frei hat und die
füllung da jetzt rein gehen kann bzw
diese kartoffelmasse aber ihm ist darauf
achten dass ihr die spritzbeutel waren
nicht so voll macht dem ist natürlich
auch abschmecken
also wenn jetzt eigentlich salz und
pfeffer fehlt müsste das einfach an der
stelle noch dazu machen denn danach es
ist zu spät da oben drehe ich das jetzt
einfach zu unten habe ich eine rosetten
thüle mit drauf und jetzt kann ich hier
kleine rosetten auf das blech spritzen
ich habe jetzt gerade gemerkt dass gm
bei mir die rosetten töne zu klein war
weil da einfach noch diese kartoffel
stückchen trinkt hängen bleiben deswegen
tauschte sich aus gegen eine stelle
nämlich oben offener als diese hier
ihr könnt aber auch einfach die
kartoffeln vorher vielleicht durch ein
sieb streichen
aber das ist nicht ehrlich gesagt zu
aufwendig und kleine eine stelle ich
auch schön
deswegen mache ich jetzt damit weiter
guckt mal sicher auch ganz hübsch aus
irgendwie sogar schöner
und jetzt spritze ich hier einfach so
kleiner tricks drauf ich habe jetzt hier
zudem ein bisschen wasser gegeben
kratzer und esslöffel und verrührt es
jetzt einfach kurz miteinander
damit ist einfach ein bisschen flüssig
wird und jetzt bestreite ich hier
diese chips einfach damit musste halt
vorsichtig sein weil die ziemlich weich
sind damit nicht kaputt gehen und so
werden jetzt die herzog den kartoffeln
im ofen bei ungefähr 175 180 grad für
etwa zehn minuten gebacken bis sie
einfach so eine schöne goldbraune gold
von wenn sie nicht aber sie werden so
ein bisschen gold und dann holen wir sie
heraus bis dahin ist auch mein fleisch
fertig und meine kuh muss fertig also im
kühlschrank
man kümmert gleich schon alles anrichten
mein essen schützen jetzt ganz
angerichtet werden und hier ist daheim
auch schon rechtlich richtig komplett
ist jetzt einfach auf so einer platte
anrichten
und wer dieses fleisch jetzt in kleine
stücke einteilen und hab das jetzt aber
auch schon etwa fünf minuten hier
draußen ausruhen lassen damit der
fleischsaft wieder sich verteilen kann
weil beim garen zählt er sich so bieten
zusammen in die mitte und dann kann er
wieder nach außen also in der mitte ist
schon noch rosa so wie ich das fühlen
konnte und außen ist aber schon durch
murat du kennst du auf den trick oder
mit dem mit dem fleisch drücken man kann
ja wenn man kein fleisch thermometer hat
also viele machen diesem fleisch
thermometer und dann kann man die
temperatur bestimmen ob im innern die
kerntemperatur erreicht ist dann weiß
man genau wie gar das fleisch ist oder
man macht es mit den fingern und zwar
nimmt mit daumen und zeigefinger und
hebt es zusammen und dann kann man hier
mal anfassen wird doch ganz weich
das heißt es ist noch ziemlich ruhe also
blutig wenn man den mittelfinger dem
zimmer wie ich es immer ganz gern
dann ist das hier bisschen fester und
wenn dann das fleisch genau die
festigkeit hat mich hier dieser dann hat
man es eben medium so ist es schon mehr
durch und so ist steinhart wie meine
mama das thema macht so kann man das hat
auch testen und dann kann man das hier
einfach auf so einer platte anrichten
diese menge reiche zu ungefähr für drei
bis vier personen je nachdem ob ihr
hatten auch eine vorspeise oder
nachspeise mit dabei habt also wenn ich
jetzt noch eine vorspeise dabei habt und
noch einen nachtisch würde ich sogar
fast sagen also die kartoffeln reichen
für vier und das fleisch wir haben halt
wenig fleisch ist auch für vier
ansonsten nur für 22
aber ich finde schöner wenn man pro gang
immer etwas weniger ist und sich dafür
umso länger schmecken lässt
sonys und richtig an
die sache ist wie eine eiskugel und
lustig dann mein fertiges menü aus mit
rindersteak kommoß kartoffeln also
heizung kartoffeln ohne bisher ist alles
fertig listen komplett ausgebrannt
dieses kindische brot gemacht indisches
brot dieses namen roth genau kann man
das so machen meint weg in dem humus
oder ich habe auch schon peter raptor
können reinschauen
ich würde sagen den teller lassen so
aber schon damit probleme wenn du willst
whistler wo muss
ich probiere
st
kartoffel hätten noch ganz kurz backen
dürfen wir sind noch sehr weit
aber das macht ja nichts schmecken
trotzdem celica ich hoffe euch hat
dieses menü gefallen und vielleicht mal
jemand nachmachen und schickt mir dann
einfach ein foto auf instagram oder
facebook twitter habe ich im moment aber
muss ich ja echt mal bald machen und zum
nachlesen gibt's dieses menü auf sex -
blog.de ich wünsche euch noch ganz viel
spaß dabei auch in guten appetit und
noch eine schöne weihnachtszeit
und wer jetzt noch nicht genug von
meinen rezepten habt dann schaut einfach
mal wieder bei bunte vorbei unten in
meiner infobox habe ich einen link für
euch bereitgestellt da kommt ihr direkt
zum video und es geht um rentiere
bis gleich